《红楼梦》第四十五回开篇,便是李文、假参串一星人来找王熙凤。假借秦凤解入社当监社浴室,实责是想让王熙凤出钱。在李文等人的言语公事下,王熙凤最终承诺送五十两赢则当设备。奇怪的是,这笔钱之后并没有出现过。直到第五十回,如雪广蒸脸及紧失,试试活动再次开启,
可举办活动的钱,居然还得重金拆一起来凑。原主是这么写的。李文道,我已经打发人笼地扛去了,咱们大家拥鲁作诗,老太太想来未必高兴,况且咱们小玩意儿,单给凤鸦特克谢尔就试了。你们每人一两赢子就够了,送到我这里来,只这乡林、保琴、李文、李奇、秀烟、五个不算外。咱们李头二压头病了不算了。
四压头告了家也不算,你们四份子送来,我包总五六两赢子也尽够了。这段文字非常矛盾。李文专门让人去请王西奉,显然是因为奉结入了设,当上了空头金色预始。
进入了设,王西奉就一定会对线第四十五回的承诺,拿出五十两赢子交设费。
可既然有了这五十两赢子,李文为什么还要向大家收费。
在以往的解读里,我们往往认为这处情节是李文铁攻击的证明,以挑定李文另色扣门的人设,甚至认为李文贪污了营养。
可细品之下,还是有许多细节对不上。
如果李文真的对设营动了手脚,其他金拆不可能看不出来。
尤其是设中有,虚保拆,假汉春,临待预这样的聪明人,满天过海几乎是不可能的,
而且自家三小姐汉春,是个眼睛里揉不得杀字的主,李文会冒着这样的风险贪污吗?
其次就是李文的人设,送然日常另色,也不过是爱惜自己的前才,他会把手伸向公共财产吗?
李文若真的这么做了,那便墮入了,幸福任赵怡娘之流,安能配得上金灵十二拆的称譽,
曹雪金恐怕也不会这么塑造李文。
我们暂且按下主观看法,单以红楼文本为根据,
中子妹问王西奉要钱发生在第45回,正是農曆九月,因为刚刚过了奉劫九月初二的生日,
期间还惹出家脸跟暴尔价的丝魂,奉劫迫促的风波,
故而,当李文来要设废时,还故意拿奉劫前天,迫促打平尔为道德之高点,令奉劫向平尔道歉。
也就是说,如果王西奉真的给了设废,那么按照起设的规矩,每月的初二十六两日,都要在李文的道乡村举办试设。
实际举办试设的日子应该是,九月十六,十月初二,十月十六,十一月初二,十一月十六,
那月初二,以及那月十六,一共七场试设。
原住第五十四回才开始过年,所以第五十回,盧学广连试发生在过年之前,
最多只能举办这七场试设,考虑到实际举办过程中,也有临时取消的特殊情况。
比如奉劫生日,恰好就是初二日,李文不得不取消这场试设,所以布红军上述列举的七场已是最高数值,实际只会比这七场少。
那么,按照正常试设花费,这七场活动能不能花完这五十两赢子呢?
这里就需要进行对比,而如何对比就显得格外重有。
比如,由某些论者拿着第三十八回,螃蟹验座对比,一场螃蟹验花了整整二十两。
若是按照这个标准,五十两赢子也只够办两三场试设,但这种对比显然不恰当。
正如欧利娟女士在大官红楼之李文论中的表述。
第四十五回中,保拆替出入试设的乡云,带伴螃蟹验环袭时,所换费的二十多两赢子,实属一个非诚态的特例。
当时除试设成员之外,连家母王父认,以及各籍家患婆子在内的,家府上伤下下数十人都共相胜举。
并各个真修理酒保祝而归,可以说是伴的热人闹闹接打欢喜。
因此买式特殊机员之下,绝无仅有的一次例外,不能以此作为推算的机准。
其次,还有第六十三回的一红叶验,习仁秦文等人一共湊了三两二千赢子,预备了四十蝶果子一弹好烧心酒,也能丰封复复给保育,过一个热闹的生日叶验。
按照一红叶验的标准,五十两赢子至少可以举办十无常试设,但这种对比不红军思认为也不精准,因为试设活动的标准比一红叶眼高,花费也不一样。
就以盧雪广连士为例,期间习仁来给假保育送胡叶挂,李丸知道习仁是未来的准仪鸟,就让下人拿一些现场的水果给习仁送去,原住写的是,李丸命人将那蒸的大预头成了一盘,又将猪举黄成赶蓝等成了两盘,命人带与习仁去。
此时正是寒冬季节,水果和等珍贵。
单此一向就可管中亏暴。
其后,夹谋也敢来错个热闹,李丸便洗手为夹母丝安全肉质,现场吃食之丰富一可见一般。
真正相对精准的数据,应该是本文开篇布红军提到的,第49回众人凑钱,李丸让宝猜,带预,碍村,宝育,每人出意量,自己再凑一些,一共是五六两赢子。
这笔钱针对的团建人数标准是十人左右。
细细属来应该是,李丸,宣宝猜,林代玉,夹碳村,夹宝玉,宣宝秦,行秀烟,李齐,李丸,香林,一共十人。
其中,夹英春生病不参加,夹西春化年化请假,也不参加。
五六两赢子用来举办十人规模的验惠,平均下来一人就是半两赢子左右。
那么在,虚,行,李,四位小姐,还没进大官员之前,一场施设的花费只需要三两赢子,最多也不超过四两。
按照这样的标准,每场四两赢子一共七成来算,花费也不过二十八两赢子。
远远不足以消耗掉王西缝所赠的五十两赢子。
除非这当中,有某次大规模验惠,就像螃蟹燕那种规模,才有可能皱然消耗掉大量摄影,
可这样的验惠,草雪琴并没有写到。
如此分析下来,这五十两赢子成了红楼梦的一个迷。
难道草雪琴写到后文,忘记了这五十两赢子,
义获者施设活动,有某次大型花费,被草雪琴误删了,这些都不得而知。
但把问题规捷到李丸贪污这个点上,多少有些难以服重。
一方面,书中并没有明确的正面描写。
另一方面,众人对李丸的贪污是而不见,也是分奇怪。
尤其如学广连诗,李丸专门命人去教凤姐参加,
眼然没有做贼心虚的情况,这其中的种种疑问,或许只有草雪琴自己,才能知道答案了。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。